so kids like this is a big decision
in general but then when you package
that big decision in with what you do
it's like i
i feel like it's so loaded did that even
play into the decision or
just with what you do i mean it's very
dangerous
well it's
it's complicated i mean it's a
it's not i mean being a professional
climber isn't fundamentally that
dangerous and within climbing there are
tons of different different aspects to
climbing you know i'm most known for
free soloing and so you know i'm sure
that's what you're referring to as as
you know incredibly dangerous
and uh and
you know that's
that's probably a fair characterization
but the thing is i'd probably be a
professional climber either way even
without the freestyling you know just
based on all the other
things that i like to climb and in ways
that i climb and expeditions that go on
you know other things that i contribute
to climbing and so
you know
i don't know we'll see basically
um
in the last year i've actually did quite
a few solos that i was pretty proud of
um but i haven't quite had any hunger
for it with the with the baby coming but
part of that is just because
uh because there's a baby coming i've
been focusing on certain things
closer to home
and and they just aren't soloing
projects i don't know it's just it's
just complicated you know it's like
where do motivations come from what
really impacts them you know it's hard
to know for sure well what's the
motivation right now then with with goal
setting
you know i often set my goals around
what's available like what's
what i'll have the opportunity to
actually try because you don't want to
set goals that are totally unrealistic
because if you know that you won't be
able to go on a trip to that place or
actually try that specific climb there's
no point in setting it as a goal if
you're never going to get to go there
and so
you know with a with our daughter coming
in a month all of my goals right now are
focused around things that are
accessible at home like basically
realistic goals that i can work on at
home and so those are all sort of like
training goals and fitness goals and
things that that uh that align well with
with having a kid so those types of
goals are are fundamentally not
dangerous you know it's all like in the
closet next to me like you know six feet
away from me is a different closet and i
have a hang board and like some some
training tools set up in that closet so
i can like work out at home with weights
and things like by dangling off little
edges and so i mean there's literally
nothing safer than doing workouts in
your own closet
you know it's a far fall yeah exactly
and so those are the types of goals that
i'm working on with with the kid on the
way
and so the thing is though then
eventually i'll take that fitness i'll
take that climbing ability and and
hopefully use it for more interesting
things outdoors
but until we have a sense of what having
a daughter is like
you know it's hard to make those plans
because i just don't know what will be
available you know
what the opportunities are sure you said
that if you weren't free soloing because
that's the big thing that you're known
for because yes it's absolutely freaking
frightening um and most people can't
wrap their head around any of it
whatsoever no people wouldn't even climb
on top of their roof without a ladder so
you know you're
you have to understand the perspective
here um
but uh what uh what do you feel like
you're
next i mean like what's the next thing
if you were gonna use this fitness what
would that next thing be i don't know
that's hard to say because with
freestyling you know it's hard to
imagine anything much bigger than
freestyling all cap which is what i'm
sort of most known for with the film
free solo
you know there are plenty of other
interesting challenges out there i mean
earlier this year i did this this link
up like a combination of three sort of
famous routes uh near my home in red
rock in las vegas
you know so they're always interesting
challenges that you can make for
yourself like that by combining classic
roots and doing
you know things that are new for you or
that are challenging
but no matter what i come up with like
that it's not going to match the
the grandeur of el cap let's say sure
and so
so i don't know i mean but that's kind
of the
the interesting thing about being a
professional climber is that there's a
there's a
big creative process to it you
constantly have to come up with
interesting goals come up with with
challenges you know think of what's
inspiring like what you know what gets
you out of bed i mean there's no there's
no playbook for it you know there are no
rules for it you just you just have to
figure out what what seems
you know appropriately exciting which is
skewed for you um so what uh
what um what would you do you were
saying like if you didn't if you weren't
free soloing you would still be climbing
and you'd still be doing all these
things how do you make money climbing
and what kind of ways to create revenue
stream
and make a living out of it would you be
able to do if you didn't sort of have
the
movie come out and and all of the things
that come around it and then of course
like i know this world well when you get
known for something then you get
sponsors and all these things is that
all still happening on a smaller scale
if you were doing that or is it more
like private expeditions or
you know what would you what would the
what would the business of climbing look
like if you took like free solo out of
the equation and doing things crazy like
that that you're getting so much
attention for
yeah that's that's the interesting
question i mean it's probably
fairly similar to the racing world in
that the
or really any professional sports where
it's like
there's
you know so you can make money for
through competitions and just direct
earnings and things like that though i
personally don't do competitions you
know like kline was in the olympics for
the first time this summer and so the
the climbers that competed in the
olympics they almost certainly have
incentives and things like that from
their various sponsors where like if
they podium they make more money things
like that
so some climbers make money directly
through competitions
i don't i
historically made most of my money
through sponsorship through like brand
partnerships with um you know climbing
specific companies and apparel companies
like i'm sponsored by the north face
they're
um
typically climbers make the most money
from their apparel sponsor because
apparel is just like a bigger category
than than climbing hardware
you know as you can imagine because you
see tons of jackets out there in the
mainstream world but you don't see that
many people walking down the street with
like climbing hardware
climbing equipment yeah exactly like
their harness on or they get it and then
beyond that
many professional climbers make money
through sort of odds and end stuff like
writing things and like appearing in
little films and you know just like
random extra i don't know like
promotional things and whatever uh you
know teaching clinics like guiding you
know all kinds of like various side
things
and then for me personally since the
film free solo my corporate speaking has
become much or just kind of public
speaking in general has become a bigger
part of everything
um and even just like movie royalties or
like commercials you know things like
that
um
but so i think if if it weren't for the
film free solo
it just would be the same but everything
toned down a little bit
you know it's like it would be the the
same buckets like the same
possibilities but just all like turned
down to seven instead of 11 let's say
yeah you know well the last time i saw
you was at a speaking engagement so
exactly i had a couple books for next
week and
all this outbreak stuff is happening i'm
like damn it do you like the speaking
engagements
i personally
do
yeah i mean i find it incredibly varied
the thing i feel like i learned
something interesting at every event
because they're always in
i don't know they're always somewhere
new with interesting people smart people
and you know industries that i don't
necessarily understand that well and so
like i did a remote speaking thing
recently for um
for uh some cryptocurrency
stuff and like i don't i personally
don't know much about crypto and i was
like oh it's actually a pretty good way
to learn quite a bit in a fairly short
amount of time so i was like that's you
know that's fine that's cool
yeah yeah yeah i i find them i actually
really have fun with them i think that
they're great
maybe it's because in the podcast i ask
questions and i try and shut up as best
as possible and when i do speaking
engagements i have an opportunity to
talk and so i'm like i'm also really
like doing that so
yeah yeah exactly um i know i mean
realistically when it's like someone is
paying you money to talk about yourself
you're like is there an easier gig in
the world you're like it's pretty it's
pretty chill
to just tell stories about the stuff
that you love most in the world anyway
you know like i could talk about
climbing with my friends all day long
because i love climbing i'm like wait if
a stranger is willing to pay me to talk
about climbing i'm like well that sounds
pretty chill it's like that's that's
what i do all day anyway it's so funny i
mean it does it it it's like i think
about that too and i think about you
know the business of speaking
engagements and just sitting there for
an hour and chatting about your life and
i'm like wow this is like stealing candy
from a baby yeah exactly but on the
other hand like you had to live the life
that you had to get that gig
you know i had to go live the life i had
to get that gig you know we had to go
spend decades we had to go risk
our lives um to be able to speak from
that place and so
you know for sure i think about how easy
it is but um the reason that you're
there is because
of all the things that you've done you
so i think i heard you've climbed on all
seven continents is that right yep yeah
actually uh i like that i've put up new
roots on all seven continents
oh wow that's beyond it um okay so i'm
most fascinated with antarctica is there
anything you want to tell me are there
aliens down there
are there tunnels going inside of stuff
that you're like hey what's that and
they're like whoops and they make you
you know look the other way
i mean is there anything crazy going on
down there well so for context we were
climbing in an area called queen modland
which is uh south of cape town so i mean
most people when they talk about going
to antarctica they go from the tip of
south america we went from the tip of
africa
um and so we were on sort of the other
side of antarctica and then we were in
an area that's like quite a ways inland
so away from the coast and so there were
actually basically no living things the
whole trip because you're just
you're in a
vast expanse of actually other
interesting fun antarctic fact is that
uh where we were at least and i think
most of the continent is actually a
desert because there's no precipitation
i mean it's it's ice it's all ice and
snow
but there's so little precipitation
because the temperature is so low that
there's no humidity
um like basically there's no
precipitation like it never rains
because it's too cold for that
and so
and it's not like it's not like it's
snowing like there are no storms because
it's basically too cold for the the air
to hold humidity
and so
um so anyway it's kind of this
interesting like
you know alien world because there's
there are no living things there's
no climate you know i mean there's
heinous wind and like it's very cold but
uh but yeah i was like it's pretty
pretty wild i mean where we were there
were these birds uh snow petrols that
come in from the coast to
hatch their their young because they're
no predators so it's like a safe space
for them to come and have their kids
and uh so for the month that we were
there all we saw were snow petrols from
time to time it's like one species of
bird that's it and then late in the trip
i found something that i thought might
have been like in on on one of the rock
walls and i was like oh my god it's a
living thing but i have no idea if it
actually was you know it could have just
been some like weird rock thing but uh
but i was like this is it's a pretty
barren landscape it's just rock and ice
well i think those are probably baby
dragons and
the living things were underneath the
ice sheet not above it
um
really deep it's crazy because the ice
sheet is so thick there i mean we were
at something like 7000 feet and
technically you know the ice goes all
the way down to sea level roughly so
it's like thousands of feet of ice where
do you climb then i mean if it's just a
sheet of ice like where's the sheet of
ice with with like actually since you're
into dragons it's like dragon's teeth
like these crazy spires of rock sticking
out of the ice so these like uh up to
two or three thousand foot granite faces
like imagine yosemite but still with
thousands of feet of ice below it and
and the the rock was much worse but but
that ice
yeah so it's like
jagged granite walls sticking out of
actually uh
all right i was like do i have a picture
of it in my in my uh you know i've got
some pictures around the uh the office
here your newly decorated office yes
exactly exactly uh but no i mean uh just
think like mountaintops sticking out of
a glacier so it's like everything is a
flat sheet of ice except for these like
teeth sticking out every once in a while
i bet that looks so crazy it's crazy
it's it's an insane landscape and uh i
mean the specific area that we were
climbing in is called uh in or it's like
norwegian it's historically norwegian
but it's called the wolf's jaw because
it looks like it's a big u-shaped uh
sort of valley and it's like oh it looks
like a jagged jawline
you know it's all the teeth of a wolf